[Applaudissements]
piazza del popolo l'une des places les
plus touristiques de rome un emplacement
précieux pour les restaurateurs les
checkers les cuillères et les casseroles
résonne
objectif faire du bruit se faire
entendre et rappeler aux politiques
l'importance de leur profession nous
sommes une industrie qui a un poids
spécifique très important qui est trop
souvent sous-estimée dans l'économie du
pays et nous représentons une richesse
économique culturel et social qui une
fois de plus a été complètement ignorés
par la politique nationale et locale
le gouvernement italien dans une
position complexe
le premier ministre a dû réagir face à
une hausse des contaminations aux
qu'ovide 19 dans son pays plus de 730
1000 cas depuis le début de l'épidémie
aujourd'hui pas de confinement
généralisée mais l'exécutif cherche à
limiter fortement les déplacements
nous prévoyons de réduire à 50 % la
capacité des transports publics et de
réduire la mobilité en provenance et à
destination des régions où le taux
d'infection est élevé sauf en cas de
déplacement pour le travail les études
la santé ou une situation de nécessité
si vous me faire mais vous me tuez le
gouvernement hors de la réalité des
pancartes avec des slogans choc pour
dénoncer le prochain couvre feu les
restaurants les pubs et les bars doivent
fermer à 18h il est inutile de fermer
les restaurants à 18h 90 % des
restaurants survie avec des ouvertures
en soirée travailler uniquement à
l'heure du déjeuner ne vous permet pas
de nourrir votre famille de donner de
l'argent à vos employés
nous demandons au gouvernement des
remboursements soit une ouverture
complète sans couvre feu soit un
verrouillage total avec un soutien
économique et un gel des impôts
le gouvernement transalpin a décidé de
débloquer 5 milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire pour aider les
professions en difficulté le dispositif
de chômage partiel a été prolongée de 18
semaines et sera appliquée jusqu'à début
mai nous avons besoin d'un fonds de
licenciement pour nos employés sur une
base régulière
nous avons besoin d'un soutien efficace
de l'argent réel qui va sur nos comptes
bancaires
le ministre de l'économie a promis des
virements pour la mi novembre dernier
délai le coup de pouce de 80 à 100 euros
par mois réservé aux bas et moyens
revenus a également été prolongé face à
la gronde des manifestants anti
confinement et des personnes qui
souffrent je sais paix compte et évoque
une course contre la montre et appelle
au sens des responsabilités